hi I'm Ryan and tonight I'm gonna be
watching the trailer for the highly
anticipated movie guardians other guys
right I'm sure by doing that alone some
people have already changed the video
but whatever that means God did not want
them to be there at this moment
everyone's talking about this damn
trailer I don't know [ __ ] about
guardians of the galaxy don't know
anything I really don't I'm not gonna
pretend like I do it's a joke I like
Chris Pratt though Chris Pratt is really
funny Parks and Rec man Burt Macklin FBI
yeah he's really funny on Parks and
Recreation and everyone's talking about
how he got cut for this film like its
stomach everyone's saying how cut he got
for the film everyone's saying how cut
he got for the film and you know Vin
Diesel as Groot and no idea the [ __ ]
it is but anyway yeah I'm gonna check
this film out and check this trailer out
right now it better be as awesome as
everyone's making it out to be because
everyone's loser to be the greatest
working thing ever so yeah okay guys
this is it moment of truth moment of
truth you guys ready
guardians of the galaxy here we come yes
it's a preview
No yeah hey go man no problem no problem
at all
who are you star-lord who star-lord
legendary outlaw for you alright alright
I'm on board
we arrested these five mountains and are
check out the rap sheets Oh John see you
Riley isn't this he the destroyer since
his wife and family were killed he's
been on a rampage across the galaxy in a
search for vengeance
Aurora soldier assassin XE rocket one on
over 50 charges of vehicular theft in a
scenario but what how brute it's been
traveling recently as Rockets personal
house plants slash muscle gain jeez Oh
Peter Jason quill he's also known as
star-lord he calls him Knight himself
he's wanted largely on charges of minor
assault public intoxication and fraud
oh I'm sorry I I didn't know how this
machine works a little of your spray hey
that's mine hey take those headphones on
oh sweet Oh daddy's guy
do this film looks badass they call
themselves the guardians of the galaxy
and a bunch of
I love it I love it I already loved this
movie and I hi max yes max I'd have sex
with our next crazy would it be to see a
porno was shot with ein X cameras like
it looks badass and it looks fun at the
same time it looks like it's gonna be
like this awesome adventure in this
total fun science fiction world I love
the tone they got going on they seem
like they were able to find a tone where
you can put in like humor and wackiness
and have a cool looking badass story
with a raccoon that kills people that
sounds [ __ ] sweet so you had
guardians of the gallon so I could act
like I know who the [ __ ] they are when I
hang out with nerds and I'm like oh yeah
Chris Pratt's character actually you
know died and the first comic but then
they brought him back it was such an
audience lover I could be one of those
douchebags